jetzt kommt sie nur wie die leute dazu
kommt ein video mit meiner schwester
leute falls der tumor ist weg können die
beste ich nehme das ganze hier sehr
behelfsmäßig auf meinem iphone auf und
das stativ auf den die kamera steht dass
er vom stapel bücher deswegen sorry
falls die qualität nicht wieder als ich
bin bei meiner familie in bayern und war
trotzdem lief machen egal ich glaube
einen klangraum er zum titel schon
gesehen heute heute rostet meine
schwester hilft mir ganz warm gemacht
gewalt zu sagen aber was euch gut
gefallen hat aber eine relativ neue
relativ unbekannte folge angeschaut weil
ich dachte ja ich dafür dir mal hier mal
da sonst das thema das schon geschrieben
und ich dass mir diese neuerung
bekannten folgen sie eigentlich
langweilig schauen wir uns doch mal
einen richtigen klassiker an und
deswegen gucken uns heute an das
absolute klassiker video mein sohn 35
glaubt er wäre ein sechsjähriges mädchen
und wir werden einfach mal frei
versuchen diese hilfe folge zu leisten
so meine kann so rentiert sollte
aufzustehen
aber ohne wird das könnte halt wirklich
es könnte unsere mutter seine die
körperlich wirklich manchmal warum tim
hat seine zeit auf dem papier
der satz klingt schon mal gefallen dann
reichen also passiv und dann bist du auf
einmal ein 40-jähriger mann der tut du
das werk eines mitteln 30
[Musik]
ich hatte das eigentlich schon verdrängt
der ja dieses video ist von 40 08 2008
ich muss sagen ich hatte das relativ
wieder verdrängt dass dieses video
investiert jetzt nicht mehr
[Musik]
doch ein bisschen etwas sagen dass
bereich nicht irgendwie unwohlsein nicht
mal warum das nicht ganz ganz wiesheu
also dass jetzt das tier ganz sicher
nicht alles gleich gehen schon mal zur
küche und bad mit dem frühstück auf dich
ich werde ja das ist nochmal so extra
ein kopftuch wenn da nur dieser bastele
ich kann ich bin noch kein baby mehr
geisteskrank
[Musik]
ganz ganz schwer
ich bin eine prinzessin und dazu dann
diese paten beine zum jahr 2020 eine
kleine schwester zu haben muss man den
anderen ja dass das futter kommt gratis
aber er hat gerade vom doppel brauchte
einen schalter zu komplex und jetzt auf
jeden fall erhöhen denn wir in folge hat
gerade mit die lager noch richtige
shisha bar und jetzt sieht er diese mit
gespart
[Musik]
denkt doch mal mit #bpw fried warum weiß
ich noch gar nicht gedacht
ja ich habe eine dachkuppel so fries
einfach sprach jeder hat in dem moment
aber patrick macht sind die bilder sonst
keiner
[Musik]
er wird auf jeden fall viele in voller
dazu bekommen weil was will das soziale
umfeld von einem stabilen ca der gerade
direkt aus der wäsche vorgang auf mich
habe ich circa und mut auf der gerade
von kurzzeit linken kommt was was wollen
die leute sehen
die wollen sehen dass sich männer als
kleine mädchen verkleidet
das wollten die sinne deswegen auch so
viele tausend euro heftige kritik kam
von rüdiger hat sich in eine traumwelt
geflüchtet und bildet sich ein er wäre
ein sechsjähriges mädchen die mutter
fördert sein verhalten und das ist weder
alters noch geschlechtstypische wie
machen die das die hitze einfach so in
den anwaltskosten und uns entsprechend
ursache sagen also diese 35 anwalts
klamotten trägt eine rote jacke
das müssen sie tragen was mich
tatsächlich diese sache stört ist auch
hat sich das nicht so ernst nimmt und
sagst du das hier ist jetzt nicht alters
oder was sagt sie und das ist weder
alters noch geschlechtstypische ich
wusste irgendetwas hat mich an diesem
irgendwas habe ich an diesem typen
gestört jetzt habe ich sein verhalten
ist nicht alters und geschlechts
typischen sie sind so froh das ist
gelebt weil sonst würde man halt kein
problem
naja ich dachte ja irgendwas stimmt da
nicht jetzt habe ich es wundert mich
also nicht dass die beiden abgelehnt und
ausgegrenzt werden
doch volker wird wahrscheinlich doch
noch zusammenhält so was habe ich noch
niemanden gesehen
ruhig war brüssel gesagt man muss auch
ein deutsches gesetz buch einfach wieder
aufrecht ist das ist
nicht das was pädagogen meinen wenn sie
sagen dass man seine kinder unterstützen
soll auch stehen aufstehen krone richten
und weiter so tun als er mal ein
sechsjähriges mädchen und buben 35 ist
leute ford folgte ein traum ich gar
nicht mehr weiß ich geh auf dich
nein nein bleibt fern
[Musik]
ja das ist das letzte was man hört man
stirbt also in dem moment wo er so
wünscht man natürlich kurz bevor so in
die nächste wetten dass die realität
wäre dann würde ich aber ganz schnell
das ewige leben finden macht bitte
einfach mach deine augen zu und dann
interpretiert diesen satz
[Musik]
das kleine kinder so sehr ich mache ja
nicht mit das kleine kinder sorgen
generieren ich weiß ich muss 13.000 euro
vertragsstrafe zahlen wenn ich jetzt
hier nicht hier bin
aber ich sag kein wort hilft mir kein
wort mehr sagen warum 13.000 euro
das stimmt das kann sich sein
der vater hat angst um sein sohn das
löste neben aggressionen aus die sich
gegen rüdiger richten ohne witz man
bräuchte ich mal so eine hilfe experte
für seine lebenslagen so dass ich meine
fotos vom vater schule legt sich gewiss
aufs maul bekommen so es sieht so aus
als hätte er die vorderradbremse zu
stark betätigt er ist über das fahrrad
abgestiegen und hatte sich an hat sich
sein gesicht verletzt
ja etwas kann an dieser stelle sagen
sollte herzen verloren haben sollten
auch autoren guten von der firma von
pippi dann tut uns das leid irgendwo
kostet ja was kann ich auch worauf ich
eigentlich dass wir dieses video
eingeschaltet hat check24 vorgeschlagen
das video ab abonniert hier oben meinen
kanal sonst werdet ihr heute nach zu
meinem 35 arbeiten wann besucht der sich
selbst nennt und wie ein sechsjähriges
mädchen redet also wollte wahrscheinlich
deswegen über abonnieren und er sagt ja
schon hausverbot